foreign
[Music]
exploratory spatial data analysis
ID
ol uh to start let's talk about
exploratory data analysis I'm sure most
of you familiar with it but good to
recap
so exploratory data analysis or Eda is
an approach philosophy or data analysis
that employs a variety of tech mostly
graphical to one maximize insight into a
data set cover underlying structure
extract variables detect outliers and
anomalies
so uh one paper for example described
Eda uh attempt to discover potentially
explicable patterns so Eda as we might
know has an emphasis on data
visualization a use of descriptive
statistics and it really emphasizes on
discovering outliers in your data set
so here are two wonderful Graphics from
the Tidy Tuesday this is how I'm
guessing most of us are familiar with uh
Eda itself
so
exploratory spatial data analysis takes
these uh takes the same Concepts and
applies to the spatial data so to
understand that we have to start with
the first law of geography which states
that everything is related to everything
else but near things are more related
than distant thing
so uh in essence esda extends
exploratory data analysis to spatial
relationship it asks questions like are
things randomly distributed in space are
there spatial outliers are close things
more similar than things that are
further away
so where Eda Compares a part to the
whole esda Compares a part to its
neighboring parts so in esda or
exploratory spatial data analysis or
evaluate a location relative to its
neighboring location not the whole or
group right
so I learned exploratory spatial data
analysis in grad school
um and I learned it through Python and
libraries like geopandas shapley and
paisal
um but it was Python and I really wanted
to use our stats so uh
uh around 2021 I wanted to get back into
this and I discovered the r package
spdap so it's a package for spatial
dependence waiting and statistics
so some things about sbap it was first
released in 2002 and it was initially
designed for SP objects which is like
the first way to interact with spatial
data in R and I'm not sure if any of you
have used it interesting and it covers
most of the spatial econometrics so
statistics weights neighbors and things
like that
but in 2002 I was six and
um I essentially grew up with the Tidy
verse so when I use spdep I have this a
little bit of like a perceived Paradigm
Gap where the way that spdap functions
is different than the way I think about
r
so um naturally when I couldn't make a
neighbor list in a mutate function call
I create an issue and unfortunately that
issue went nowhere so
um my response was to create a tidy
interface called sfdap so sfdf is an
interface and extension to spdep for
spatial dependent
and some principles are that I always
want to use SF objects for geometry
that's what I'm familiar with and most
people might be always return dply or
friendly objects so lists data frames
factors and then additionally
functionality shouldn't be dependent
upon D buyer for those who don't want
fire
and then additionally all functionality
that I have additional functionality is
implemented using spdep object like
backward compatibility
and then so fundamentally with
exploratory spatial data analysis we
need to understand our name and to do
that we'll use the St contiguity
function which takes an sfc class object
or the geometry column of an SF object
and returns a list for identifying your
neighbors
here's an example that using the flyer
friendly code
and the result is a list with where each
element is an integer vector and the
elements contain row positions of its
neighbors
and we're not just limited to
identifying contiguity for polygons we
can Implement finding K nearest
neighbors distance bands so on and so
forth
and additionally if you want to use
spatial weights we just pass in the
neighbor object the spatial weights and
we get row standardized by default
so here's an example of doing all that
in one call with mute date
again we're not just limited to that
let's compare the syntax so here's a map
of comparing clusters of crime in 1830s
France here's the code for using spdep
it was no pipe operator and lots of
assignments here's the same result using
sfdap one assignment and two pipe
operate
so here's the same map same different
code same result
so sfdap doesn't uh just act as an
interface it extends it as well so we
can do local join counts the first open
source implementation of co-location
quotients and also implements esri's um
emerging hotspot analysis
it also integrates with SF Networks
so what's next user validation ensure
parity with python and then make a hex
logo one day
so give it a star and give it a go
all right
[Music]